[Music]
happy Christmas Eve it is the night
before Christmas and thus my wife and I
watched The Nightmare Before Christmas
this is my beautiful wife Sam hi
everybody thank you for joining me on
this review of a holiday classic but
what type of holiday classic is it is it
a Christmas movie is it a Halloween
movie it's been debated for years
I'm curious to know what your thoughts
on this are because I actually don't
know what you're gonna say it's a
Christmas movie yeah yeah cuz it's
basically about Jack learning what
Christmas kind of is or him attempting
to learn what Christmas really is it's
less about like the characters and their
celebration of Halloween it's all about
them trying to learn how to have a
Christmas and what the warm feelings are
and the joy and the peace and the
goodwill and you get the point I'll say
it's more Christmas than it is Halloween
Christmas is in the title of the movie
there's definitely a Christmas message
as you said I think one of the reasons
this movie is so popular beyond the
incredible animation and the great music
is that it does kind of fit into the
best of both worlds like someone who
loves Halloween can watch it and for all
the creepy imagery like you and I but
someone who also loves Christmas can
watch it for the warm-hearted message
and for the meaning of Christmas and all
that stuff so it kind of is that rare
movie that for me is both it's it's hard
to find a movie like that that can be
watched at different times of the year
for two different holidays like you said
it's definitely more towards like the
Christmas cheer vibe because when this
movie is basically about is Jack
Skellington the pumpkin king who's like
the master of Halloween and he discovers
what Christmas is and he for some reason
wants to recreate it but he doesn't
really understand how to recreate it
he's just thinking of just the the base
like physical stuff well we have to have
presence we have to have a guy with a
beard and reindeer
he doesn't recognize like the true
meaning yet he thinks that if he just
has all the little things in place then
he'll have a Christmas and that people
will appreciate it so yes it is
definitely more towards them kind of
tearing apart the ideology of Christmas
presents the reindeer the Santa Claus
and that honestly when it comes down to
it you don't really need those things to
have a warm holiday experience because
let's be real not everybody has the
ability to have the presents and the
great family or everything like that so
there's a little bit more of a darker
you don't always have the perfect
scenario to have a holiday that's one of
the things I noticed sorry watching it
tonight was that it is one of the most
dour and depressing and like dark black
movies that is also somehow cheerful
it's extremely sad a lot of ways you
have Sally who is constantly trying to
poison her creator which is kind of
hilarious for a family movie like her
life is awful she can jump out of
windows and break every bone in her body
and well stuffing in her body or
whatever it is and it's leaves and then
so herself back together there's a lot
of darkness in this film which I love
one of the things I loved about it Tim
Burton produced the movie he's often
credited as the director he's not yeah
the director is Henry Selick or celiac
I'm not sure how to pronounce his name
he also made James and the Giant Peach
and Coraline which is my favorite of his
films and so it has that Tim Burton
Flair Danny Elfman did so much of the
music and he wrote the songs he even
plays the singing voice of Jack
Skellington whereas Chris Sarandon plays
the like the acting parts with a
dialogue and so it feels like a movie
that Tim Burton would make but it has
the flair of Henry SELEX other
productions like James and the Giant
Peach and Coraline he has this great
darkness to his films that somehow
maintain the ability to be family films
but have so many adult themes yeah cuz
Timber who's straight productions
where he's the director a lot darker
then the the those other ones are their
little less family-friendly in regards
they still have a good meaning to him in
for Tim Burton but some of them home and
their their dark very dark so for me
this film my holidays were not always
like ideal I guess I related to this
film or because I was not in the
situation where I had those great
childhood memories of holidays and
things like that so for me is slightly
dark and twisted taking apart the yes
commercialism a pop the holiday and
taking that and stripping it kind of
made me feel a little bit better about
my situation so it was nice I just felt
I just felt so bad for you all of a
sudden okay I mean it could have been a
lot worse I wasn't in a better scenario
than a lot of people are this earlier so
I mean for a lot of people they see
parallels of Jack obviously depression
serious case of depression there sadly
being very concerned for his depression
and nobody else kind of really noticing
just how bad Jack is mm-hmm
they both are longing for a different
type of life Jack's life he's lauded
he's respected everyone likes him but
he's not he's just bored he's been doing
the same thing over and over again and
so he feels like he'd like to do
something different and like you said
it's making him depressed
Sally obviously as we already said is
trying to kill her creator and so she
obviously isn't too happy either so it
is a very it has a lot of adult themes
yeah it has and I definitely didn't
notice them until I got older the adult
themes so that's definitely a play on
like peeling towards adults more than
little kids being their favorite films
but me the sick twisted child that I was
I was like oh there's a werewolf there's
a vampire I like all the creepy gory
stuff I was not the typical child and
that respect I'm like the scarier the
better please I'm gonna go watch horror
because I'm like an eight-year-old child
watching the Pet Sematary yes
me like I loved it that's one of the
reasons why movies like this appeal to
me so much is because in fact all my
favorite Christmas per-say movies are
usually the ones that aren't your
stereotypical ones like die hard or any
of Shame Black's films or this I do love
the home alone movies which are more
normal Christmas movies but even those
it's not like Christmas with the Kranks
or you know national lampoon's vacation
it's like this movie where this kid
basically tortures and maims other these
burglars so I love weird dark twisted
holidays it's not a Christmas story
today we've seen a lot of stop motion
films but when this came out it was
pretty impactful there were obviously
other stop-motion animated things in the
past a lot of older films you
stop-motion quite a bit to achieve like
various monsters and incorporate them
into live-action but the scale of this
production and the camera movements and
the incorporated visual effects like
zero the dog floating around or the big
yellow moon in the background like these
things are so gorgeous that even today
watching it all these years later
knowing what you can do on a computer I
still look at this movie and I'm blown
away by just the construction of the
scenes by all of the effects that have
been incorporated to make everything
move fluid and there's also this really
charming imperfection to the animation
that just makes it so gorgeous because
you can sometimes see the clay shift and
mold a little bit and you can tell okay
well maybe that was a little bit of a
mistake in that frame but it there's
something even about that that makes it
even better yeah it's it's crazy how
much detail they paid to this whole
thing like little things you would never
really think about like the individual
snowflakes and the fluffy snow and the
egg shape piece that he grabbed is that
when he reaches down into the snow and
it's just like this perfect round don't
almost snow it's like they just they
paid a lot of attention and it's
something that I don't think studios do
that much anymore which is a shame
because if anything technology's gotten
better for them to be able to pay more
attention to things like that so there
a new movie I saw in a song I don't
remember when I saw it exactly but it's
not that old called strange magic and I
can't say that I was all that impressed
with the CGI and are the computer
animation in this and it was just like
when you take something that's new and
compared to that old and old is still
outclassing these new productions you
just have to stop it to wonder how much
are they really paying attention anymore
two things are they're just letting the
computer kind of do all the work and not
realizing you stopped to go in and add
things to make it look imperfect because
two perfect takes away the edge of the
reality of this definitely and not to
like you know crap all over CG movies
because I mean a lot of them are really
beautiful but strange magic is a great
example because I didn't review that
film but yeah the animation itself was
just very bland and basic and dull and
when you look at a film like Nightmare
Before Christmas about a hundred people
work on this movie for three years just
moving these characters meticulously and
that's not even talking about the camera
movements so it's pretty impressive I
mean it's there's just something so
beautiful about the way this film looks
that the style really leaps off the
screen and that's one of my favorite
things about it is just the music and
the look and the feel of the picture I
have a few issues with the movie nothing
too huge lock shock and Barrel those
three guys have their own little song
that I don't care about this scene like
it's part of my least favorite song in
the movie see that it's like 76 minutes
and so I can feel a little rushed
sometimes characters go through really
insane arcs in the middle of a song and
sometimes you're like okay I'm catching
up with the storytelling here but I mean
that's that's these are really n
consequential things I think this is a
gorgeous movie and one that's very
unique in that it's somehow combines two
holidays yeah and creates this really
entertaining film with great music and
something else I really respect is that
Tim Burton has basically denied studios
from making any sequels I did a little
reading on the film and apparently in
like 2001 Disney wanted to make a sequel
and they wanted to do it CG fully
computer and Burton said no he didn't
think that was a good idea a lot of
people have come to him saying well you
could do other holidays there's
the area in the forest with Thanksgiving
and Easter and you can have a whole
Nightmare Before Christmas or nightmare
before Thanksgiving universe of movies
and each time he has denied them the
rights to make this sequel because he's
very protective of the film which i
think is really neat yeah just because
this one is so great you don't have to
make more and I really respect him for
doing that even though personally I
would love to see more yeah um maybe
even if it's um something like a five
minute short that took place in the
front of another film I would love to
see just even something like that just a
little clip but I mean I have to respect
him for not doing it because it's like
why kind of why bother just don't mess
with greatness right right they I think
studios are having this mass thing
they're doing is they're taking really
great films trying to remake them or add
sequels to them and just it kind of
ruins some of the originality of a piece
when you just start tacking on more
things to it instead of me just leaving
it alone yeah which is why I'm glad that
they've they've never done that this
movie yeah it's always been its own
thing not that I don't want them to it'd
be nice but it it'd be nice but it'd be
scary yeah does that mean that's not
always talked about with this home is
actually the romance in this between
Jack and Sally
everybody was focuses on more the other
stuff but the romance between Jack and
Sally is very sweet
it's very almost innocent in regards to
Jack not really paying attention to
Sally and realizing what he has in front
of him until the end of the film and
it's it's very emotional because it's
like he's grown more through this
experience to be able to now recognize
what he has which is Sally yeah I feel
sorry for Sally for the majority of this
movie because she's the voice of reason
she's the only character that's like hey
maybe you shouldn't do that
maybe that's a bad idea and everyone's
like yeah yeah okay yeah whatever yeah
okay we'll just whatever Sally and and
she's kind of the unsung hero of the
whole movie she's like what I call the
audience character she's the one that we
look at and go yep that's exactly what I
was thinking she's right she's like the
mouthpiece for us you see Jack trying to
sabotage Christmas and have it his way
and I'm gonna go kidnap Santa and have
everyone do what I want to do for
Christmas and she's like ah
maybe not I don't flee so much is trying
to sabotage it as he was trying to take
it over yeah I guess sabotage isn't
really the right word he's just trying
to recreate it for himself in the wrong
way yeah because he didn't have joy in
his own holiday anymore and like we said
he's just he's depressed and he's kind
of now revitalized himself through this
action so I mean obviously Sansa forgave
him at the end of the film yeah so kind
of cleared up Jack's depression I guess
through this action of just trying
something new and getting himself out
there and falling in love and so the
message to everyone out there is try
something new and don't steal holidays
that's bad just don't steal yes don't
steal sometimes you can poison people if
you don't like them if they're being
mean to you
you can put stuff in their soup and yeah
that's probably the best way to handle
that it's totally the message that was
going for yes don't actually poison
people no you can it's fine no don't
encourage life they know not to poison
people no weird people out there anymore
yeah don't poison people it's bad yeah
also go to school and yeah like you said
the score and this is amazing oh these
are so good all of the songs in they
just they flow so well and it's just my
favorite is um when he first sees all
the Christmas stuff is what's this
what's this
I need dancing around that's probably my
favorite one I have to say it's like I'm
getting so sick of like pop songs being
turned into music scores in every kid's
film yeah
trolls does it every animated movie
basically every animated film lately has
had ripping just pop songs choose throw
into it and you're just like they'll
have some kind of electronic dance song
where they all dance at the end for the
last two minutes emoji move the trolls
the list goes on and on and just I'm so
sick of it and I love children's films
are my favorite type of film because I
like to watch films that make me happy
not impressed and have to fund
like doing the emotional roller coasters
I just want to sit down and just be
happy when I watch a film because it's
funny smell makes you happy yeah it's
the credibly depressing sad I like I
said I was a dark and twisted child who
wore a lot of black and I I happen to
have a fascination with the creepy stuff
and the McCobb yes yes I was there
really very much an Edgar Allan Poe
person obviously I had the big book I
still have the book and read mom just
like he starved heart this film is
sophisticated it doesn't pander it
doesn't look down on kids it doesn't
assume that kids don't understand deeper
themes and it has deeper themes in there
and if you're young and you see it and
it went over your head when you're older
you can be like okay so that's I knew I
liked good movies when I was a kid damn
it I can't imagine what in 10 years what
some of the kids in ten years that are
watching their current new movies are
going to say in ten years about what
kids maybe when I was five I just loved
watching the emoji movie so much oh my
god he's 30 and he's like oh I still
watch Beauty and the Beast I still watch
the Little Mermaid I still watch The
Lion King I still watch move on and I
still love them because they're still
great films and it's just I can't I
still can't bring myself to think like
oh my god what is kids gonna say when
they remember trolls or minions or any
of those characters that are super
annoyed with your dogs honestly giving
me like like war flashbacks about
sitting through those films Nightmare
Before Christmas beautiful film by the
way nice tree that my wife made do you
think yes you made this oh yeah she made
this oh yeah it goes next to our
Halloween city that I have a literally
year-round in our house because I do
have a whole village that we use leave
it yes oh you're right that's creepy
everywhere and it's that's yes and
remember children poison people you
don't like
because
that's always the best way to deal with
things and if you want to escape your
house you can always jump out of your
window and then get crushed
all of your body parts will fly off but
you can attach them away we don't need
losses from you saying this to kids and
them doing this they're not beyond it
they're not gonna do it we're not gonna
do remember to underpin case that's true
anyway let's let's change it up what
would you give the nightmare equalizer a
plus yeah
well I will give the nightmare before
christmas and a oh by the way you have
to make a pact with me back pack yes in
fact yes when we do have kids there's no
way in hell we're letting them watch any
of those annoying movies you have to
pre-screen them so that I don't even
have to bother hearing them in our house
that's not a pact that has to be made
because I'm never sitting through the
emoji movie or minions or any of that
again if my child comes to me and
says daddy I want to watch minions I'll
say you're not my child
clearly something happened that went
wrong and it's time for you to jump I
don't Despicable Me movies it's just
hard minion movies and trolls are mode
you movie or anything along those lines
I just I can't handle that I don't want
them good to get addicted to it I just I
don't need that in my life that would
give me an aneurysm
yes all right thank you guys thank you
very much as always for watching thank
you to my lovely wife for joining me in
this video and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes happy holidays everybody
[Music]